welcome back many local businesses have
been financially impacted by cobit but
one company
is bringing the community together to
help ceo and co-founder of threads of
envy mitch klein joins me to tell
us more about one of the coolest
clothing companies in the country
what you guys are doing we know you're a
big favorite of a lot of the las vegas
golden knights
and now you are giving back to the the
community mitch let's talk about this
what is the vegas fun that you created
and why did you create it
so the vegas fund is um
going to be a a program that we're doing
to
help local companies and small
businesses that have been
financially impacted um by covid
so what we're going to do is we're going
to allow
businesses to submit applications um
into through our website at support
threads of mb.com
we're then going to offer a shirt to the
public and
allow that to be purchased and then take
those funds and donate them back
to the businesses that have been
selected to be a part of this program
now this is really cool because then do
these companies logos
go on the shirt on the back of it yes so
we'll put every business that's been
selected their logos will go on the back
of
our local t-shirt um and i don't know if
you've you've seen that but it's the
local with the state of nevada inside
the o
um so you know we're gonna you know keep
it based around
our community all the logos will go on
the back
and uh that way that they get you know
an opportunity to be shown
through our community and um and then
yeah then those funds that the shirt
purchases
once those are purchased those phones
will be donated to those selected
businesses
now if a business is interested in uh
being considered for this you said go to
the website what do they need to do
just submit the hardships that they've
been going through what are you looking
for
yeah absolutely so basically all they
need to do is email us
at support threads of envy.com
um send in your logo just a brief
summary of how you've been
impacted financially due to covid um
and we will yeah and that'll go through
february 26th
we'll then launch the shirt on march 1st
now are there a certain amount of
businesses that you're going to be
selecting
yeah up to 50. up to 50. so that's great
now as someone who would love to support
the community you said they're rolling
out the shirts in march how do i get one
where do i get one so you just go to
www.threadsofenbe.com
we'll have it right there on the home
page for people to
purchase and support you know local
business
what a great thing you guys are doing
you're always so supportive of
the community mitch thank you so much
las vegas now we'll be right back